สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษา
ไทยห้องเรียน comprehensible ไยค่ะค่ะ
แล้วในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบ
กับนักเรียนอีก
แล้ววันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะครูปุ๊กออวันนี้
วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะมีนาคมค่ะปีพ.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2567 ปีค.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2024 ค่ะนะฮวันนี้ก็ตรงกับวันจันทร์ที่ 4
มีนาคมพุทธศักราช
2567 คริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะ
อวันนี้เราก็มาเจอกันอีกแล้วแล้วแล้วแล้ว
แล้ววันนี้เราจะมาคุยกันเรื่องของชื่อค่ะ
ชื่อชื่อชื่อเล่นชื่อ
จริงชื่อฉายาอืชื่อไปนามปากกาเอชื่ออะไร
คะวันนี้เราจะคุยกันชื่อเล่นค่ะ
อ่าชื่อเล่นก็ส่วนมากแล้วคนไทยก็มี
ชื่อเนี่ยของตัวเองเนี่ย 2 ชื่อนะอื 2
ชื่อน้อยที่สุดนะ 2 ชื่ออือหือ
นะชื่อเล่นกับชื่อจริงอือหือชื่อจริงก็
คือตามบัตรประชาชนค่ะใช่ค่ะในบัตรประชาชน
ของเราแต่ละคนค่ะก็จะมีชื่อนะชื่อจริง
แล้วก็นามสก
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยชื่อในบัตรประชาชนเวลา
ทำพาสปอร์ตก็ใช้ชื่อตามบัตรประชาชนค่ะอือ
แต่ว่าถ้าชื่อเล่นเนี่ยเออนะไม่ไม่ใช่ทุก
คนรู้จักชื่อเล่นเราใช่มยใช่ค่ะต้องเป็น
คนที่สนิทแล้วก็รู้จักเราแบบใกล้ชิดเพราะ
ว่าอะไรเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยชื่อก็ยาวนาม
สกุลก็
ยาว
นะจะเรียกชื่อจริงหรือชื่อเล่นอย่างูชี้
ชื่อยาววชิราภรณ์
อืมชื่อยาวนะูปุ๊กเนี่ยสั้น
กว่า
ธิดาอือนามสกุลล่ะคะจรลีชาญชัยค่ะนามสกุล
ยาว
ค่ะเห็นมั้ยคะนักเรียนเพราะฉะนั้นกว่าจะ
เรียกเรียกชื่อหรือจะใช้นามสกุลมาเรียก
มันยาวเกินไปค่ะคนไทยก็เลยต้องมีชื่อเล่น
นะฮที่เรียกสั้นๆนะเรียกสั้นๆในสมัยก่อน
เนาะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็นิยมมีลูกเยอะๆค่ะอืมี
ลูกเยอะๆถ้าจำชื่อจริงเนี่ยน่าจะยากเลยนะ
ูชิก็เลยคิดตั้งชื่อเล่นไว้เรียกง่ายๆไอ้
ดำไอ้แดงไอ้เขียวไอ้เหลือง
อืออันนี้เนี่ยตอนนี้น่าจะไม่ค่อยมีคน
อยากชื่อแบบนี้แล้วค่ะนะไม่มีคนเอาชื่อ
ของสีมาตั้งเป็นชื่อเล่นเออนี่แหละความมี
เสน่ห์ค่ะมีเสน่ห์ก็คือไม่เหมือนใครคนไทย
เนี่ยตั้งชื่อเล่นแบบหลากหลายมากค่ะเรา
เคยคุยว่าเรามีชื่อสัตว์ที่คนมาใช้เป็น
ชื่อเล่นเช่นกระต่ายอืลิงช้างก็มีคนตั้ง
เป็นชื่อเล่นถูกมยค่ะเป่าก็มีค่ะอืมมีใคร
ชื่อยุงมั้ย
คะอาจจะน้อยนะอาจจะน้อยหรือเราเคยคุยว่า
มีผลไม้อืนะแล้วก็มีคนมาตั้งเป็นชื่อเล่น
วันนี้เราจะคุยกันเรื่องผักค่ะค่ะโอผลัก
เนี่ยนักเรียนไม่ค่อยรู้จักชื่อภาษาไทย
เท่าไหร่เนาะนะวันนี้ก็เลยเอาผักมาให้นัก
เรียนดูว่าผักอะไรบ้างที่เราเอาชื่อของ
ผักเนี่ยเอามาชื่อเป็นชื่อเล่นของคนด้วย
เออนักเรียนอาจจะรู้สึกว่าเฮ้ยคนไทยเนี่ย
แปลกทำไมเอาชื่อผักนะเอามาตั้ง
อทำไมค่ะ
บางอย่างเนี่ยเราไม่ตั้งเป็นชื่อเล่นนะคะ
แต่ถือว่านักเรียนจะได้รู้จักชื่อผักของ
คนไทยด้วยนะใช่ค่ะ
นะหัวใช้เท้าไม่ใช่แพหัวใช้เท้าอ้าครูชิ
คะหัวใช้เท้าเนี่ยมีคนเอามาตั้งเป็นชื่อ
เล่นด้วยหรอมีมั้ยคะครูปุ๊กหัวใช้เท้าหัว
ใช้เท้าเนี่ยกินอร่อยค่ะแต่มันมันมันฟัง
แล้วมันเหมือนเท้าอ่ะค่ะใช้เท้ากับใช้
เท้าเวลาเราเดินเราใช้เท้าเดินนะเค้ากับ
เท้าไม่เหมือนกันแต่มันใกล้กันค่ะูชิน่า
จะไม่มีใครอยากชื่อน้องหัวใช้
เท้าใช่มเราจะไม่ได้ยินเนาะใช่ไม่เอาไม่
มี
ค่ะแล้วเห็ดล่ะคะเห็ดเห็ดเนี่ยอบางคนอาจ
จะชื่อได้นะครูชิ
นะบางคนอาจจะเออนะน้องเห็ดน้องเห็ดอาจจะ
แบบคนไทยไงบางทีเนี่ยคุณแม่นะตอนท้อง
เนี่ยท้อง 1 เดือน 2 เดือนเนี่ยจะอาเจีย
อึอื้อแล้วก็แพ้ท้องแล้วบางคนเนี่ยอยาก
กินนะอาจจะอยากกินอะไรก็ได้นะเคก็จะเอา
ชื่อนั้นแหละมาตั้งเป็นชื่อลูกง่ายดีมยคน
ไทยอะไรง่ายๆสบายๆค่ะแม่อยากกินเห็ดกิน
เห็ดทุกวันชื่อน้องเห็ดเลยอือันนี้อาจจะ
มีนะอ้าเออถ้ากินพิซซ่าทุกวันก็ชื่อน้อง
พิซซ่าเออเออเห็นมยง่ายๆตั้งชื่อเล่นที่
แบบเรียกง่ายๆเข้าใจมีที่มาที่ไปใช่ค่ะอ
ต่อมาค่ะเผือกเผือกจริงก็มีนะมีคนชื่อ
เผือกแต่ส่วนมากแล้วแบบบางคนผิวขาวๆนะเขา
ก็เลยมาตั้งชื่อเผือกนะ
อ่ามีดีเจไงดีเจที่เปิดเพลงอ่ะในรายการ
วิทยุอ่ะชื่อพี่เผือกอ่าสวัสดีครับทุก
คนใช่มนักแสดงก็มีค่ะชื่อเผือกอ่ะ
อืแต่ตอนนี้นะคิดว่าไม่มีใครตั้งชื่อลูก
ว่าเผือกแล้ว
ค่ะเพราะว่าเผือกเนี่ยมันมีคำ
แสลงที่แปลว่าชอบไปยุ่งเรื่องคนอื่นไงใช่
ค่ะคือเมื่อก่อนมันก็ไม่ได้แปลแปลแบบนี้
หรอกแต่ตอนเนี้ยเเอาคำนี้เนี่ยมาใช้ใน
แสลงนะแปลว่าชอบไปยุ่งเรื่องของคนอื่นนะ
ที่เขาไม่ได้อยากให้เราไปยุ่งอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะเขาก็จะเรียกอุ้ยทำไมเผือก
จริงๆมันมีภาษาตรงใช่มั้ยแต่ฟังเขาก็รู้
สึกว่ามันไม่โอเคแรงเออก็เลยเรี่งเสียง
ที่คล้ายๆกันก็เป็นเผือกนี่แหละค่ะเขาก็
เลยไปทำเป็นแสลงคือคำด่าจริงๆเขาใช้คำว่า
เหมือนๆเอาไม้เข้าไปไปยุ่ง
เรื่องคนอื่นเขาแต่มันฟังดูแล้วมันมันแรง
ไปเขาก็เลยเรียกแบบเสียงคล้าคล้ายๆก็เลย
ใช้คำว่าเผือกแต่เผือกเนี่ยมีชื่อเล่น
ของคนไทยจริงๆใช่ค่ะแล้วมันแกวล่ะคะมัน
แกวมันแกวเมื่อก่อนมีนะครูชิครูชิก็เคย
ได้ยินไงมีคนที่ชื่อเล่นว่ามันแกวน้อง
มันแกวะะพพอไปๆมาๆเก็จะอาจจะเรียกเป็น
แก้วแก้วเหรือสั้นๆนะคำหลังตัวเดียวไง
พยางคข้างหลังเนาะแก้วไม่ใช่แก้วแก้วแก้ว
นะมันแก้วนะคะใช่แต่ถามว่าชื่อแก้วมีคน
ตั้งเป็นชื่อเล่นมั้ยมีมีค่ะอือาจจะมาจาก
นกแก้วก็ได้นกมาคอนกแก้วอ้าไม่ใช่แก้วกิน
น้ำใช่
มั้ยไม่ใช่นกแก้วไงเพราะว่านกแก้วเนี่ย
พูดเก่งส่วนมากนกแก้วเนี่ยเขาจะตั้งเป็น
ชื่อผู้หญิงไงชื่อแก้วเนี่ยผู้หญิงนะแกว
ล่ะมันแกวเนี่ยจะเป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะ
มันแกวเนี่ยมากๆที่ได้ยินเนี่ยเป็นผู้
หญิงนะอืเพราะว่าตัดเหลือแกวแกวอย่าง
เดียวก็จะแบบนะฟังแล้วเสียงมันน่าจะซอบๆ
นะก็อาจจะแล้วเผือกล่ะคะเผือกเป็นผู้ชาย
นะอืชื่อเล่นของผู้ชายนะคต่อมาค่ะ
ขิงขิงเคยได้ยินชื่อเล่นขิงมยน้องูชิเคย
นะเคยได้ยินมีเด็กที่ชื่อขิงค่ะน้องขิง
อ่าขิงไม่ใช่คิงขิงใช่คุณแม่น่าจะชอบกิน
อะไรที่เผ็ดๆอ๋อเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นคนจีนน่ะ
เขาจะชอบค่ะไทยจีนเค่ะนะคนไทยเชื้อสายจีน
ก็ได้เพราะว่าเลือดเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นแบบ
บรรพบุรุษมาจากประเทศจีนเนาะนะแต่มาอยู่
ที่ประเทศไทยนานแล้วแล้วแล้วก็ลูกมีลูก
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้วเขาก็มีความเชื่อว่า
ถ้ากินขิงเนี่ยมันจะให้ความร้อนในร่างกาย
ค่ะเวลาคุณแม่คลอดลูกใหม่ๆเนี่ยกินแต่ผัด
ขิงค่ะทุกทุกวันทุกมื้อต้องมีผัดขิงค่ะ
กูชิคุณแม่อาจจะรู้สึกอ้ายให้กินแต่ขิงๆๆ
ให้ชื่อน้องขิงซะเลย
อ้าขิ่งนี้ก็เป็นแสลงเหมือนกันนะใช่นะชอบ
ขมคนอื่นนะก็
อือย่ามาขิงกับฉันนะอืโชันสวยค่ะฉันสวย
กว่าตั้งเยอะ
อสวยแต่ไม่แพงไง
คะเห็นมอันนี้เค้าเรียกขิ่งก็คือข่มกัน
น่ะเหมือนแบบอือฉันดีกว่าฉันดีกว่าฉันดี
กว่าจะดีกว่าหรือจะรวยกว่าหรือจะอะไรอะไร
ก็ได้เนาะสวยกว่าดีกว่าอะไรอย่างเงี้ยค่ะ
นะเค้าเรียกขิงโหเอ้ยไม่ต้องมาขิงกันเลย
นะของอย่างงี้มันก็ต้องขิงกันบ้าง
อืต่อมาค่ะค่ะแตงกวาแตงกวาเนี่ยมีค่ะนะมี
คนชื่อแตงกวานะนักเรียนบอกโอ๊ยทำไมชื่อ
แบบนี้เสำหรับคนไทยน่ารักนะผู้หญิงหรือ
ผู้ชายคะแตงกวาผู้หญิงค่ะนะเพะเพราแตงกวา
เนี่ยจะเย็นๆนะเหมือนมีน้ำชุ่มชื้นไงอ่า
แตงกวาน้องแตงกวาแถวบ้านครูชีก็มีค่ะน้อง
แตงกวาออน่ารักมั้ยน่ารักค่ะผอมๆตัวเล็ก
ๆไม่น่าจะเรียกแตงกวานะแตงกวาน่าจะกลมๆ
อ้วนๆออต้องเป็นแตงร้านเหรอ
คะหอมๆเล็กๆน่าจะชื่อกระเจี๊ยบค่ะ
กระเจี๊ยบออกเสียงดีๆ
นะเจี๊ยบกระเจี๊ยบอืกระเจี๊ยบเนี่ย
กระเจี๊ยบก็มีนะมีชื่อเล่นนะ
อืกระเจี๊ยบกับน้องเจี๊ยบ
อ่ากับลูกเจี๊ยบเออลูกเจี๊ยบก็คือลูกของ
ไก่นะตอนตัวเล็กๆมันจะเป็นสีเหลืองนะเรา
จะเรียกว่าลูก
เจี๊ยบมีทั้งเด็กผู้หญิงและเด็กผู้ชายนะ
ชื่อเล่นว่าเจี๊ยบ
ถ้าเป็นชื่อว่ากระเจี๊ยบนี่จะเป็นผู้หญิง
ค่ะอืกระเจี๊ยบเนี่ยก็จะเป็นชื่อผู้หญิง
มากกว่าผู้ชายอื
อเพฉะนั้นเนี่ยกระเจี๊ยบเนี่ยก็จะมี
เหมือนกันเนาะแต่น้อยนะูชิใชอ่าต่อมาค่ะ
อะไรคะต้นหอมอ่ามีคนชื่อเล่นว่าต้นหอมมะ
มีค่ะเป็นดีเจด้วยเป็นนะคนไทยน่าจะรู้จัก
กันเยอะค่ะเพราะว่าเขาเป็นดีเจเป็นผู้
หญิงค่ะที่มีชื่อเสียงอยู่ค่ะนะดีเจต้น
หอมนะก็เป็นผู้หญิงนะต้นหอมนะคะอ้อ้ต่อไป
ค่ะน้องผักบุ้งออผักบุ้งมีค่ะนะผักบุ้ง
ผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะผู้หญิงค่ะูชิอผัก
บุ้งฟังเสียงแล้วน่ารักนะน้องผักบุ้งเ้า
แล้วมีน้องกระเฉดมยคะกระเฉดกระเฉดมีมั้ย
ครูชิครูปุ๊กไม่เคยได้ยินแถวบ้านครูชิก็
ไม่มีเด็กที่ชื่อกระเฉดนะแต่ถ้ามีเด็กที่
ชื่อกระเฉดนะจะเป็นผู้ชายค่ะผักบุ้งนจะ
เป็นผู้
หญิงรู้จักเสียงไงคะน่ารักหรือว่าแข็งแรง
นอืนะชอมค่ะมาใกล้ๆสิคะูชิชะอมค่ะชะอมอัน
นี้ใส่ไข่เจียวเนาะทอดแล้วก็กินกับน้ำ
พริกอร่อยมากค่ะชะอมมีมั้ยคะมีชื่อชะอม
มั้ยมีค่ะเป็นเด็กผู้หญิงค่ะน้องชะอมน้อง
ชะอมอื
อื้อหือชคิดว่าคุณแม่ตอนท้องน่าจะชอบกิน
ชะอมอน้ำพริก
ด้วยปต่อมาค่ะต่อ
มาอะไรคะ
คูชิมะนาวค่ะมะนาวเห็นลูกซะใหญ่นึกว่าส้ม
โออ่ะแล้วมันเป็นผักตรงไหนอ่ะมะนาวค่ะ
อ๋อมะนาวเปรี้ยๆเลยส้มโออันเนี้ยเล็กลงมา
ะ
มะนาวใหญ่เส้ม
โอน้องมะนาวมีค่ะนะ
ผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายคะผู้หญิงค่ะอุ้ยทำไม
แบบชื่อเล่นผักนี่มีแต่ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง
เยอะมากเลยค่ะโหมันดูน่ารักๆรไงครูชินะ
ถ้าผู้ชายชื่อแบบน่ารักๆรมันจะดูไม่แข็ง
แรงนะชายต้องดูเข้มแข็งอมีพาเวอรมี
พลังผักต่อมา
ค่ะ
อ๋อผักกากาดค่ะแต่อันเนี้ยเป็นผักกาดหอม
ที่เราไปกินสลัดเนาะหรือไปแต่งจานกินกับ
อะไรก็ได้เนาะใส่ห่อแล้วก็กินโอ้อร่อยค่ะ
ใช่ผักกาดอันนี้มีมีชื่อเล่นมั้ยคะส่วน
มากก็จะมีน้องผักกาดค่ะไม่รู้ผักกาดหอม
ผักกาดขาวผักกาดเขียวผักกาดแก้วไม่รู้แต่
ว่าเขาจะชื่อน้องผัก
กาดน้องผักกาดก็ยาวแล้วนะถ้าบอกน้องผัก
กาดหอมผักกาดแก้งยาวไปอีกค่ะใช่ค่ะก็เอา
แค่ผักกาดพอและ
อือชื่อเล่นส่วนมากเจะตั้งไม่ยาวไงูชิต่อ
มาค่ะผักนี้คือผักคนาคน้าอืมีคนตั้งเป็น
ชื่อเล่นมั้ยมีมั้ยคะูชิของูชิเคยเจอค่ะ
เป็นเด็กผู้ชายค่ะชื่อคะน้าผมคน้าครับออ
กุชิก็เลยบอกว่าหนูคะน้าเนี่ยฟังแล้วหิว
ข้าวเลยถ้ามีหมูกรอบอีกอย่างนึงคะน้าหมู
กรอบจะอร่อยมากขัดกับปลากระป๋องก็ได้ค่ะ
คะน้าปลากระป๋องก็
อร่อยคิดว่าน้องคะน้าได้ยินคะน้าจะบอกว่า
ทำไมคิดถึงกินผม
ครับเอ้าก็ผักคะน้าเนี่ยมันเอามาทำอาอาร
ได้หลายหลายเมนูไงหลายๆอย่างเนาะไม่ว่าจะ
เป็นข้าวผัดก็เอาใส่ผักคะน้าได้นะคะน้า
เอาาไปผัดกับปลาเค็มไปผัดกับปลากระป๋องไป
ผัดกับหมูกรอบอะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะมันก็เลย
แบบเวลาเราคิดถึงอ่ะเอ้อมันอร่อย
นะผักนี้ค่ะ
กระเพากระเพรามีมั้ยมีคนชื่อกระเพรามั้ย
คนไทยชอบกินกระเพราเยอะค่ะแต่ชื่อมาตั้ง
ชื่อเล่นเนี่ยครูชิว่ามันยาวไปนะแล้วชื่อ
มันคงไม่เพราะกะเพราน้อง
กะเพราเอ๊ะมีมั้นะหรืออาจจะไม่อาจจะเรา
อาจจะเคยได้ยินเค้าเรียกว่าเพลาเพลาแต่
อาจจะมาจากกระเพราก็ได้นะูชินะอือันเป็น
ก็อาจจะมีคนที่ชอบกินผัด
กะเพราก็เลยไปตั้งชื่อลูกว่ากะเพราอ่าตอน
ท้องชอบกินกระเพราหรือเปล่าอือฮึนั่นน่ะ
สินะเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วกระเพราเอ้ยกะเพรา
ก็มีประโยชน์ประโยชน์นะ
อือะไรคะูชิถั่วพูถั่วพูถั่วพูเออถั่วู
หรอมีมั้ยครู
ชิน่าจะเคยมีมีคนตั้งที่ถ่วูมั้ยเหมือน
คุ้นๆเหมือนเเออน้อยมากน้อยแต่น้อยมากนาน
ๆจะได้ยินภู
ภูน่าจะรู้สึกเหมือนเป็นผู้ชายนะถภูอืแต่
ว่ารุ่นใหม่เด็กรุ่นใหม่ไม่มีชื่อแบบนี้
แล้วค่ะไม่ตั้งชื่อเป็นชื่อผักแล้วใช่
มั้ยออแล้วก็ไม่ชอบภาษาไทยแล้วด้วยเดี๋ยว
นี้เตั้งเป็นภาษาอังกฤษหมดอ่ะค่ะ
ออกระเทียมค่ะมีมั้ยคะน้องกระเทียมน้อง
กระเทียมไม่ไม่เคยได้ยินนะ
ดูชิมีแต่กระเทียมโทนแล้วน้องโทน
เกระเทียมโทนมันจะเป็นกระเทียมที่มีกลีบ
เดียวเนมันเป็นหัวกลมๆเล็กๆค่ะนะแล้วก็มี
อันเดียวไม่มีกลีบเล็กๆหลายๆกลีบด้วยกัน
นะก็เรียกกระเทียมโทนโทนแปลว่า 1 อ่ะเนาะ
น
อโอพี่พริกหวานพริกหวาน
นะพริกหวาน
อ๋อเคยได้ยินแต่น้องผักหวานเพริกหวานยัง
ไม่เคยอ๋อเป็นน้องผักหวานเอ่านะคแล้วแน่
นอนมีคำว่าหวานเี่ต้องเป็นเด็กผู้หญิงแน่
ๆใช่ค่ะถูกต้องนะพริกหวานแต่ว่าพริกหวาน
เนี่ยมีมั้ยมีใครตั้งชื่อมยยังไม่เคยไม่
มีนะเออรู้สึกเผ็ดไงพริกนะมีแต่น้องหวาน
นะมีแต่น้อง
หวานถ่วงงอกเ้ยมีมั้ยอ่ะูชิถ่วงงอกไม่เคย
ได้ยินน่ะอืมเพราะงอกกับหงอกมันใกล้เคียง
กัน
ค่ะนะถัว่งอกอันนี้โอเคค่ะถ้างอกหงอก
เนี่ยผมเนี่ยเปลี่ยนเป็นสีขาวผมหงอก
แต่ถ้าผมงอกเนี่ยเริ่มขึ้นเนี่ยนะแทงออก
มาเนี่ยผมงอกเนี่ยโอเคอหงอกเนี่ยไม่โอเค
แก่แล้วสีขาวอันนี้ถั่วงอกถั่วงอกก็คือ
มันพึ่งแบบต้นมันแพงรากออกมาเนาะมันก็แบบ
ตื๊ดออกออกมาจากถั่วใช่ใช่มมีถั่วแล้วก็
มีงอกออกมาใช่ค่ะงอกัวงอกไม่มีเนาะไม่น่า
จะมีคเื่อก็ไม่เคยได้ยินอืต่อมาค่ะ
กระชายอือกระชายมีมั้ยคุณูชิมีค่ะของูชิ
เคยได้ยินออนะน้องกระชายนะแล้วเป็นชื่อ
ของเด็กผู้ชายด้วย
นะกระชายเขาบอกว่ามีประโยชน์ค่ะฟังดูแล้ว
แข็งๆไม่หวาเพราะนั้นไม่ค่อยมาตั้งชื่อ
เป็นของเด็กผู้ผู้หญิงนะ้าเด็กผู้หญิง
อะไรนะผักบุ้งหวาา
อกาศกระชายเนี่ยเสียงแบบกระชายแบบมันต้อง
ผู้ชายค่ะใช่ค่ะนะกระชายอันนี้ก็เอามาทำ
อาหารหลายๆเมนูเหมือนกันเนแล้วก็มี
ประโยชน์ค่ะมันเป็นสมุนไพรค่ะเป็นผักที่
เหมือนเป็นยานะไม่ต้องกินยาพาราเซตามอน
ไม่ต้องกินยาสำหรับให้แก๊สมันออกมาค่ะกิน
กระชาย
ค่ะต่อมา
ค่ะหน่อไม้มีมั้ยน้องหน่อไม้หน่อ
ไม้หน่อไม้เนี่ยน่าจะเป็นต่างจังหวัดเด็ก
เด็กต่างจังหวัดน่าจะถูกตั้งชื่อว่าหน่อ
ไม้ไปขุดหน่อไม้แล้วก็คลอดลูกตรงกอหน่อ
ไม้พอดีออือแล้วถ้าเป็นชื่อหน่อไม้เนี่ย
ก็ต้องตั้งเป็นเด็กผู้ชายค่ะใช่ค่ะดู
เหมือนจะแข็งแรงเนอะนึกถึงคำว่าไม้มัน
แข็งอือืเนาะหน่อไม้ก็เป็นแบบต้นไผ่เนาะ
แล้วก็มีหน่อออกมานะหน่อ
ไม้ต่อมาค่ะผักต่อ
มา
มะระมะระน้องมะระโอ้โหยไม่น่าฟังเลยคุณ
ูชิเพราะว่าเราจะนึกภาพเนี่ยผิวน่าจะไม่
เรียบค่ะผิวนผิเหมือนระอย่างงี้ใช่มคะเออ
มะระน้องมะระมะระขี้นกย
ยาวขมด้วยค่ะไม่น่าจะชอบค่ะไม่น่าจะมีใคร
ชอบมาตั้งชื่อเ
อืมะระน้องแครอท
แครอทอือมีมั้ยกูชิมีน้องแครอทเป็นเด็ก
ผู้หญิงด้วยนะน่าจะตัวสีส้มสีชมพูเออหรือ
ไม่ก็เกิดปีกระต่ายไงชอบกินแครอทกระต่าย
ชอบกินแครอทไม่เรียกน้องผักบุ้งคะกระต่าย
ก็ชอบกินผักบุ้งเหมือนกัน
อ้าแต่เขาบอกว่ามันจะคู่กันไงนะอืแครอท
ผักบุ้งอ่ะประเทศไทยไงกระต่ายไม่รู้ไม่มี
แครอทกินตอนหลังเนี่ยถึงจะมีเยอะค่ะ
มันล่ะคะมันน้องมันเอ้นี่มันฝรั่งมันเทศ
มันเทศน์น้องมันเทศน์ไม่น่ามีนะคุชิมี
มั้ยเคยได้ยินมยไม่เคยได้ยินน้องมันไงมัน
ฟังแล้วมันไม่ไม่น่าตั้งชื่อเรียกเด็กๆ
ใช่มันไอ
มันไม่เพราะว่าเราเรียกเรียกเอ่อเป็น
สรรพนามที่ 3 อยู่แล้วนะนถึงสิ่งที่เราจะ
พูดถึงอย่างกุปุ๊กกับูชิคุยกันเนี่ยครู
ปุ๊กก็จะเรียกตัวเองว่าครูปุ๊กนะหรือ
เรียกูชิว่าูชิอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนะอันนี้
เรียกแทนตัวเองหรือไม่ก็ฉันเธอนะแต่เวลา
เราพูดถึงคนที่ที่เราพูดถึงเนี่ยนะเป็น
บุคคลที่ 3 เนี่ยก็คือเราก็จะใช้เรียกบาง
ทีเนี่ยอาจจะพูดถึงหมาถึงแมวถึงสิ่งของนะ
อนะก็เราก็จะใช้คำว่ามันได้นะอือหูแมวที่
บ้านเนี่ยมันซนมากเลยค่ะนะมันในที่นี้คือ
แมว
เออ
นะโอเคเพราะฉะนั้นเราไม่เอาคำว่ามันเนี่ย
มาตั้งชื่อมอืใช่ค่ะเราก็เลยไม่ใช้เนาะ
เพราะว่าคำว่ามันเนี่ยมันใช้เรียกเราจะ
รู้สึกไม่ดีถ้าพูดถึงแบบใครแล้วเรียกว่า
พูดถึงเพื่อนแล้วบอกโอยเพื่อนเนี่ยมันไม่
ดีเลยมันเนี่ยแสดงถึงเราเนี่ยไม่ชอบเค้า
เท่าไหร่นะจะเรียก
ผมหรือไม่ไม่
สุภาพไม่ต่อมาค่ะสตอโอ้โหอันนี้น้องสตอมี
มั้ยความหมายมันไม่ค่อยดีค่ะคือตอนเมัน
เป็นแสลงไงแต่สมัยก่อนมันอาจจะไม่มันไม่
ได้เป็นแแลงเอาจจะมีหรือเปล่าไม่รู้ส
เพราะว่าเป็นอาหารภาคใต้ที่เาชอบกันนะนะ
แล้วมันมีกลิ่นที่แรงมากอืใช่ๆนะคะแต่ถ้า
เป็นอันเนี้ยค่ะหน้าตาคล้ายๆสตอค่ะเรา
เรียกว่ากฐินกิอืมกฐินมีค่ะมีคนชื่อ
กระฐินค่ะมีเยอะด้วยนะเออกฐินเนี่ยมีคน
ตั้งชื่อเป็นชื่อเล่นเยอะมากเพื่อนครูชิเ
เนี่ยมีชื่อกฐิน 2 คนอืแล้วก็เป็นผู้หญิง
ทั้ง 2 คนเลยอีกคนเนี้ยผิวดำเชียส่วนกฐิน
นคนน่าจะเป็นดอกกฐินไสีขาว
า 2 กฐินเนี่ยไม่ได้เหมือนกันเลยนะ
คน่าจะเป็นต้นกับ
ดอกเออนะเพราะดอกของกฐินเนี่ยมันจะเป็น
แบบเหมือนกับดอกหญ้านักเรียนกลมๆขาวๆสวย
น่ารักอือแล้วน้องกฐิน
นะมีมีตั้งเป็นชื่อเด็กผู้ชายมยไอ้กระฐิน
อาจจะมีได้นะเสียงมันแข็งแรงก็ได้นะูชิ
จริงๆอ่ะชื่อของเสียงมันน่ะมันดูแข็งแรง
นะแต่ทำไมมาตั้งเป็นชื่อของเด็กผู้หญิงนะ
อาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าดอกกฐินมันสวยนะดอกขาวๆ
ดูกระทินน่ะอือือฮึเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคนที่
ชื่อกฐินเนี่ยต้องเป็นผู้หญิงที่ดูแข็ง
แรงอื
นะไก็ไปได้ว่าถ้าเป็นแบบต่าจังหวัดเก็จะ
ปลูกทุกบ้านนะอมันเป็นผักที่แบบหากินได้
ง่ายเห็นได้ง่ายอะไรอย่างงี้ไงอร่อยด้วย
ริมรั้วใช่มั้ย
ใช่
บวบบวบอ่ะมีนะน้องบวบบวบครูชีก็เคยได้ยิน
แต่มันเป็นรุ่นเก่ากว่าเราอีกค่ะใรุ่นคุณ
ป้ารุ่นคุณแม่เนี่ยจะมีเพื่อนที่ชื่อบวบ
อื
บวบบวบยายบวบอืดีค่ะ
นะแล้วตำลึงล่ะคตำลึงมีนะ
นะเพราะว่าเวลาสุกแล้วเนี่ยลูกตำลึงมัน
สวยไงสีสวยนะตำลึงน้องตำลึงแล้วภาษาเมื่อ
ก่อนเนี่ยเงินก็มีเงินที่เราเรียกว่าเป็น
ตำลึงด้วยไงอื 1 ตำลึง 2 ตำลึงนะคะแพงค่ะ
ค่ะคนชื่อตำลึงก็ต้อง
แพงฟักแล้ว
่ะอันนี้ฟัก
แม้วไม่มีอ่ะค่ะอันนี้สมัยก่อนอาจจะมีนะ
ครูชิอืเพราะว่าไม่ได้คิดถึงชื่อฝรั่งนะ
เป็นชื่อไทยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราก็ตั้ง
หรือว่าเรียกกันแบบเราก็ไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไร
ไง
มะเขืออันนี้ก็มีนะมะเขือแต่ไม่ใช้มะเขือ
เทศนะชื่อมะเขือเป็นเด็กผู้ชายอมะเขือ
มะเขือโอ๊ะหมดเวลาแล้วอ่ะมีน้ำต้งน้ำเต้า
อีกนะจริงๆมีผักอีกเยอะเนที่คนไทยก็คือคน
ไทยคนไทยอ่ะตั้งชื่อแบบง่ายๆไงง่ายๆที่พบ
เห็นได้ง่ายๆนะหรือว่านะเห็นเยอะๆก็ได้นะ
ก็เอามาตั้งเป็นชื่อเล่นเรียกง่ายๆจำง่าย
ๆใช่หรือเด็กคนนั้นชอบกินอะไรใช่มก็จะ
เรียกแบบนั้นนะคะอย่างอย่างมีรุ่นน้องคน
นึงชื่อแตงกวา
เาไปเรียนที่เกาหลีค่ะเขาก็เปลี่ยนชื่อ
แตงกวาเป็นโออิเป็นภาษาเกาหลีที่แปลว่า
แตงกวาพอถึงเวลาเขไปแนะนำตัวอิโออิทุกคน
ก็ค
หัวเราะใครเอาชื่อผักมาตั้งชื่อเล่นมี
ประเทศไทยประเทศ
ไทยประเทศไทยนี่แ่ะไทยนโอลี่
ค่ะมีประเทศไทยค่ะเอาชื่อผักมาตั้งเป็น
ชื่อเล่นเอาชื่อหมาแมวเนี่ยมาตั้งเป็น
ชื่อเล่นของคนเอาชื่อผลไม้มาตั้งเป็นชื่อ
เล่นโอ๊ยยังมีชื่อเล่นที่เป็นของใช้ด้วย
นะคโอกาสหน้ามีทั้งของใช้ของกินไงโอกาส
หน้าเราค่อยมาคุยกันใหม่อีกทีวันนี้มัน
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะุุได้ค่ะไว้โอกาสหน้าเรามา
พบกันใหม่ค่ะวันนี้ก็สวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ